Japan says it has finished testing all crew and passengers...
...on board the virus-stricken Diamond Princess  cruise ship.
All passengers who tested negative for the coronavirus are expected to disembark from tomorrow.
Foreign governments are eager to evacuate their nationals...
...aboard the virus-hit Diamond Princess cruise ship...
...after the confirmed infections rose above 540.
The US government evacuated more than 330 people from the cruise ship yesterday.
Among them, 13 have been tested positive and three people show likely COVID-19 symptoms.
All of them were taken to the hospital on arrival...
...while other evacuees have been placed under quarantine at military facilities.
Canada has also sent a chartered plane to Japan today.
According to a government statement, all passengers will undergo a two-week quarantine.
South Korea is also sending a government charter flight today...
...to bring back its four citizens and one Japanese spouse.
Currently, none of them are showing any symptoms.
The Australian government is planning to bring home more than 200 of its citizens tomorrow...
...and they will be placed under a two-week quarantine on arrival.
Italy and the UK are also working to organize flights to repatriate their nationals...
...stranded on the ship.
A British couple quarantined on board tested positive yesterday.
Hong Kong will have, on standby, two chartered planes as early as tomorrow.
Residents of Macau will also be able to get on same plane.
Twenty-one out of the 350 Hong Kong residents on board the ship has been infected.
The Philippine government has also made plans to repatriate its nationals on the quarantined ship.
The Philippine Embassy in Tokyo says more than half of the crew,...
...some 530 people, are Philippine nationals.
There are also seven passengers from the country.
So far, 27 of them have been tested positive for the virus.
Remaining passengers who have tested negative will begin disembarking as early as tomorrow,...
...that's the original deadline for the end of the ship's quarantine.